how's it going breasts
my name is Pierre 2pac and welcome back
to the wolf among us so we just left off
at the from the intro of the first
episode third one faith and we're
heading back to our apartment to meet
the girl I would all know to the
woodland luxury apartments it's late
nice I find it hard to believe that he
lives in a luxury apartment bed maybe
this is someone else
what is this
stay off the grass
be a disciplinarian you mean snow-white
what a [ __ ]
alright let's go inside oh maybe
everyone lives in this apartment
no and that's impossible what's that
what yeah don't make me come over there
make me come over there look I've got an
hour of paperwork ahead of me and I've
already had to deal with one [ __ ]
that night so just sorry Big B didn't
mean to be an [ __ ] really beautiful
beauty in the Beast hello baby stay off
the grass I wasn't expecting anyone how
do you hide looks a little odd why'd you
hide well I didn't know who it was
can't be too careful these days what day
are you talking about okay
damnit I'm late and why were you hiding
there doesn't make sense
she's the killer
promise me you won't tell Beast you saw
me
you worries too much as it is
it would just make my life a lot easier
okay fine I promise you promise I just
told you thank you baby
I'll explain it all to you later I will
but I have to go
what the hell is she up to thank you for
trusting me
really I I appreciate Big B
you bros always say I make the wrong
decisions so I hope I hope I didn't make
anyone upset by Lego cuz I always do
somehow there's only someone butthurt
over it I don't know let's let's give
the girl some trust okay
so I'm saying you're nari I was trying
to Ryan didn't work out but is our
apartment whoa what the flicka this suit
of armor that looks bad eh yes now what
that mace she needs it does this guy
let's talk to him hey you wake is he
look awake yeah probably for the best
wise I can we can touch it still asleep
huh well let's check our mail
been a while since I got any mail it
hasn't happen a friends they're all
wolves they don't know how to write in
our own way to count waiter Digby's
nametag what does that him thing fell
off again I'll say he's not been living
here for long right how much longer is
this gonna go on
so we live in two or four that's a smart
way to make us know and I'm gonna go
away from here oh yeah I forgot I can
move I forgot this is not an adventure
game well I guess it is
sorry I just hey hey alright let's go
upstairs
oh it is working I thought it was for
what we're not working ok later
alligator
I like the fight or whatever who's this
douche is that is that East wait up
no no no you've seen my wife have you
seen Beauty ah hmm
um so have you I'm not lying to anyone
okay I'm just gonna be like mother did I
make the wrong decision again
huh come on
oh my mother forgot how my mother [ __ ]
oh I don't see nothin god damn it
hey is there a relationship troubles not
mine okay I'm staying out of it
you know you hand me you heat you her
this employee phone damn should've
cracked a window
isn't it late
his beard looks like and an antara night
what is known let's check the
refrigerator why do I even own this
hufflepuff smaller you need to defrost
that ice bra well they're not gonna
refill himself jeez
alright let's get our work done
Bluebeard's file
never trust this guy his blue beard
don't even remember ordering that
probably a bad sign
probably a good sign not you eating okay
let's keep looking at in our flight that
one what the [ __ ]
what are you doing here
oi Colin boy call it
get up you fatty you fat pig
huh hey Big B I'm in your chair huh yeah
you are
and there's only one end I got the one
so yeah is that his pet as one ugly-ass
pet it's a sexy Oh got a smoke hey Pig
some smoke how would you even smoke with
those hooves you [ __ ] stop of course
Thanks you have to like couple thousand
more of these will be even on that house
you owe me this has got to stop
you can't keep sneaking off the farm
like this the fresh air and sunshine
pitch they sell you on is [ __ ] I
didn't escape out of the homelands to
end up in some prison okay don't send me
back there big B you don't know what
it's like okay you haven't been there
come on
that's a little dramatic
what remember what I don't know for me
sure nope the house didn't blow itself
down Big B that's all I'm saying
do with that what you will now I'm not
saying it's reason enough for me to have
definitely been offered a drink but it
would have helped these some of the pain
you once caused me yes it also would
have shown everyone how different you
are now from why let's just take a sip
nice I take it all back this is why
everyone hates you you brothers wanted
me to play the bad guy part better to be
fair it is better to be feared and loved
you know said that yeah
some sad [ __ ] eating alone but no um
hates the wrong word they fear you more
than anything you ate a lot of people
back in your day oh yeah we were all
supposed to have a fresh start here I
can't change the pattern
well you can't change people's memories
either let's all thunk I'm not saying
it's fair but it's real people are
scared of you I mean look at your hands
I had a knuckle biting contest no one
who'd you get in a fight with a fable
right I'm sure you're not going around
punching Mondays it's my job okay I was
doing my job
believe it or not your job is to beat
the [ __ ] out of fables well he came out
of times I'd take him to the farm
what's up with the FARC you why but dad
didn't even mean to be mean you little
peg don't swear a Pyxis think my job is
easy you try keeping a bunch of fables
from killing each other how do you think
this all works
I don't know how should I be big and
being bad by being big and being bad
don't say that [ __ ] in front
hahahaha terracing that's the attitude
that gets you in trouble
I'm sure you were shitty to everyone you
came across tonight night
not everyone named one beauty and the
girl I don't actually know her name I'm
more interested in the girl awesome
great example life is easier with
friends Big B and we live a long [ __ ]
time I know you like this whole lone
wolf thing you got going for yourself
but I've seen the way you look at snow
okay you're not fooling me will you shut
up
oh well maybe if my throat wasn't so
farst I wouldn't have to keep talking
wait that doesn't just get a drink
please
yeah darlin enough already I haven't
slept in two days
I went out a second-story window and I
want to get in two seconds of shut-eye
before I look if I give you this will
you let me sleep yeah yeah all right
probably
that let's give him the drink I mean why
not what why does he want to drink so
[ __ ] much
geez Oh is a pig of course is greedy
thanks Big B are you gonna drink it just
tell me how oh damn that is nasty
I thought you were gonna do the
paperwork
my paperwork is gonna write itself you
know oh [ __ ] it's a go
yes or it could be the Huntsman or the
Woodman sorry the woodpecker the wood
man pecker damn Sam I'm hello I want to
open right away I want to see if it is
baby that's know right come with me so
he's big being she's big boobs no I mean
so yes that's right snow what sorry I'm
what is it what happened happened oh
[ __ ] I just can't get into it the second
we need to hurry to where the [ __ ] are
you hello good morning or evening huh
yeah what it's not all about these walls
are paper-thin we need to be careful
we'll talk outside
I like your shirt that's snowflakes on
it what was that oh [ __ ]
oh damn that's what you get for sleeping
at work I guess
uh-oh it's just a jacket sorry I'm blind
apparently jump-scare jump-scare I'm
scared
no no no you knew this girl no she's not
a Mundy what the [ __ ]
who was she back [ __ ] I knew everyone
in fatal town she looks familiar
I can't place her though god damn that
wood man is going down I feel like
there's something you're not telling me
well you're the doing the same oh yeah
she has a thing in her mouth the
woodsman
I stepped in and he threatened to kill
us both
no you don't think he oh he didn't think
anything yet just give me a second
it's just
here it took me a second to realize what
I was even looking at so who found her
yeah I did she was just like this I
didn't touch her I grabbed grimble's
jacket to cover her with oh I came to
get you right away no one else was with
you
no big P did one of us do this there
hasn't been a murder in Fable town in a
long time
all the more reason we shouldn't start a
panic before we know what's going on
what the hell man have a look around I
thought she wasn't have much time before
people will be coming through here I
really like that girl like it was
interesting that's a [ __ ] shame man
well let's get the thing in her mouth so
she's in no nobody's
oh dude oh dude is that a condom it's a
ribbon Oh some kind of symbol here huh I
I don't recognize it there was something
about it strange god what did this to
her an axe what could do something like
that an axe either something very sharp
or something with magic attached to it
she was placed here with some care what
do you mean you can see that someone
didn't just toss her here she was
deliberately placed for us to find well
that's kind of obvious there woods man
that [ __ ]
uh-oh I'm sorry this is just so surreal
what's her job in exactly and what what
do you want to do next
Willy
nothing much else to do
we should move her before anyone shows
up we'll find out more at the business
office she'll be in the books I'm sure
of it pigby do you have any idea what's
going on
this is the methods why her this is a
message a message I don't know baby I
get complaints at the office all the
time but just what about this makes you
think that whoever did this isn't
exactly hiding it the placement of the
head it's exact purposeful she was
placed here precisely for us to find all
of us well yes I guess you're right
the killer wanted us to know what they
had done I'm gonna have to tell crane
about this no as long as King Cole is
gone
he's acting mayor he needs to know and
he's going to find out anyway so we may
as well get out in front of it wait
until we have more to tell him right now
all we know is a girl is dead
telling crane doesn't change that it
I've got all the motivation I need to
find out who did this
that sounds reasonable but I don't know
I'll think about it I just don't want
him interfering cranes not what's
important right now we need to figure
out who this girl was
so we can find whoever did this well we
have a clue not to dr. Swinehart this is
my look at it I'll meet you at the
business office ah geez alright well we
have our we have our murder case to
solve
super interesting I hope you guys are
enjoying this they'd be like if you did
subscribe cumbre today I'll see you
tomorrow in the next one
my door is ringing thousand buzz love
you Maha yes don't jump-scare me
don't you dare jumps cami
looks like gmod ragdolls